we had another beheading video from Isis
steven sotloff who is an American
journalist have it's a gain for your
actions to get another American citizen
so just as your missus continued to
strike our people our knife will
continue to strike the necks of your
people because of your insistence in
continuing your bonds in our monies and
modern the most of them despite our
serious warnings you Obama have yet to
gain for your actions could get another
American citizen so just as your massage
seems to strike our people our knife
will continue to strike them okay so we
obviously didn't show the beheading
itself they're YouTube's taking the
videos down Twitter is banning people
that post it but I wanted to at least
get you guys the message on that this of
course comes about two weeks after they
did the same exact things to James Foley
another American photojournalist and
supposedly now they have a British
journalist that they plan on doing this
to end it and apparently there's about
20 other people that they have being
held hostage right now I mean we've been
doing this every week now you've been
tweeting a lot about this just this sort
of savagery that we're seeing how do we
make any sense of what's going on over
there well this is the way I've been
thinking about it lately
I mean it's horrific and it's it stopped
me in my tracks and even when the video
came up in the studio here I like I
don't even want to like I don't want see
the whole situation
trigger warning like you know all that
kind of stuff but and this is gonna tie
into a future topic we've got going
today but basically this shit's been
going on a long [ __ ] time and the
fact that we now have it videotape and
high production value I want to add
that's kind of the creepiest part of all
of this but this has been going on in
humanity for tens of thousands of years
or at least I don't know but at least a
couple of thousands years with
civilization and war and empires and all
that so it's horrific and it's insane
and yet welcome to the human species I
don't know what to say it's it's just I
it's just so much for me yeah so let's
just talk about the video
themselves do we have to show these
things because you know when Twitter
banned all the people for putting up the
video I kind of think you have to have
access to it so we know what's going on
of course you don't want to push out
their propaganda and all that stuff but
what do you think about just showing the
videos themselves because some people do
want to see the the part that we didn't
show their eye I would never want to see
the part that they didn't show I mean I
have enough imagination left to fill in
that horrific black oh yeah but I think
you have to have access to you know as
to has to be some form of a free media
you have to show these things to educate
and inform yeah so that's a great point
so you show it in a situation where you
are educating and informing but just
having it loose on the internet for and
for and bless you youtuber comments
commenters for youtuber commenters to
talk about you know how gay he is and
sucking his dick or something I don't
know that that worries me
you know people using it to discuss
geopolitical situations terrorism trauma
whatever it is yeah sure but I don't
know I don't think people should be
tweeting this [ __ ] alright so that being
said let's not get too hung up on the
beheadings themselves but apparently
Isis is actually much bigger than we
thought we've got some interesting info
here so two quotes here the first one is
from a security expert in Baghdad he
said the Islamic state didn't come from
nowhere it's an extension of groups that
existed before historically and
ideologically okay that's not major news
the second one here from a political
analyst in Jordan I thought was the
interesting one the Islamic states
members have multiplied in a very
dangerous way having plenty of arms and
funding has made Isis swallow the
fighters of other Sunni insurgents so
basically they're just combining all
these groups that we funded half of them
and the ones that we didn't fund now
they have their weapons now they're
saying there's about a hundred thousand
of them two weeks ago they thought there
was 40,000 of them
there's tons of British people like the
guy who who did the beheading in that
video is this one of these things where
the u.s. is just damned if we do damned
if we don't if we go in more people hate
us we don't do anything more people get
killed but nobody else is going to do it
so we're Jess I think I think it is in
the dam do we it's almost like trying to
invade Coachella
you took Coachella and Burning Man and
had them attack each other and then
whatever was left over those people
became Isis I'm actually with you on
this and I really think that if we think
about it in the raw numbers of a hundred
thousand that's where we can we can
target and have a strategy like a
hundred thousand people that's about 750
porta-potties six service so we just
look for a caravan of porta-potties bomb
the s out of that guess my kids are
watching yeah you know seriously I think
that's that's we're looking at yeah yeah
going with I mean what do we do do we
buy now everyone seems to be for bombing
me you know no troops but just send some
plugs how did this all well how did this
mess start 12 years ago yeah because we
bombed Iraq that's how this mess started
look when you take dictators like Saddam
Hussein and Assad and Syrian people like
that who like really rule with an iron
fist these tribal regions and you remove
them you get a lot of tribal energy and
blood and beheading and [ __ ] like that
goes on this you know the scary thing is
these people have access to money and
arms and you know things like that now
and bigger things and hopefully not
dirty bombs and [ __ ] like that
I'm hoping that they they're the
infighting will start because it always
does with these groups I'm pretty
inviting a start yeah and inviting even
in the Isis will start and then but also
when I watched a video I don't anyone
saw this of an Iraqi TV show they still
have them there believe it or not with
some Arab gentlemen and Arab headdresses
I don't know if that makes I think that
makes them Sunni and anyway I'm not not
an expert in any of this they were
sitting around talking about the the the
Christian community in some of these
cities and how they're being targeted
and one of these men in full Arab
headdress
began weeping for his Christian friends
and I was like hope hope hope hope hope
so
there's a lot of humanity left in these
countries a lot of humanity in the
population we need to support those
people yeah with ways to combat these
bad people but so how do you support
humanity right like everyone agrees with
that right that sounds good we have to
support humanity humanity's not usually
supported by bombs it's ugly
you know nobody gets their house bombed
you know there will be bombing yeah
he'll be killing yeah what about the
rest of the world why is it always us is
it because everyone knows that we're
sort of addicted to intervention like
they know that they don't have to do
anything like really England France is
what we do but doesn't show man we're
the Superman country what doesn't it
show like sort of what a farce the UN
and NATO and everything really is
because at the end of the day it's about
us whether we like it or not right well
it's about I think whoever has the most
toys and the most money but but that's
and the best Doc Martens I mean our
boots will be on the ground again in
that era do you really think so
supposedly yeah well supposedly this
morning Obama sent 350 more troops
that's obviously nothing but it's it's
something guys yeah charge of finding
those porta-potties yeah yeah yeah all
right so last thought on this and then
we'll move on to some happier stuff but
with all these reports about all this
stuff and now you know Rick Perry not
that I like to quote Rick Perry but he's
saying they're coming through the border
in Mexico and today they found this guy
in yeah that's what he's saying and they
got this guy in in Minnesota who was
working for Delta who apparently left to
go fight for Isis so is it it's
something gonna happen here I mean we're
in evitable right like it's just
inevitable time to invade Texas if
they're coming through Mexico or dicks
at all I'm not looking at you Austin
yeah that's a reverse if you give
someone that's reversing yeah oh yeah
okay Isis try to give them Texas
yeah then they'll be pissed yeah what do
you think though I mean is it's
inevitable like something yeah you
there's no way they can protect us from
every single possible a little bit of it
I mean no matter how many shoes they
check at the airport yeah I think I mean
we have to be vigilant and yet there's
too many people there's too many ways to
travel there's too many forests to climb
through something something will happen
and that's frightening and scary and I
think there's the parallels from history
I mean that's one of the things I really
respect about you is your ability to
remember stuff and I'm not talking about
for breakfast tomorrow or yesterday but
you know if you look at the first world
war and what happened there with with
the Huns you know with the Germany and
then how that set the stage for the sons
of that yeah not unlike we're hearing
that it's it's ecstasy
Saddam military guys and their sons when
I heard that I'm like oh oh so this
becomes around the the communal fire
whether that be a stove or an actual
fire it's they're remembering how their
days of glory and they're passing that
anger and that desolation and that lack
of opportunity to their sons who are now
joining a movement which ended up
becoming a right right and you know in
Germany in the 30s there's a lot of
parallels that when you decimate a
culture and you don't fly over that
culture and drop a bunch of Sears and
Roebuck catalog so they can see how to
rebuild yeah what will fill that void is
usually anger vehemence and yeah well as
I think I've said every week we should
be dropping PlayStation stead of bombs
and then maybe they have something to do
or porn or what else she wanted people
to pour in PlayStation got anything else
with P pop popcorn potato chips potato
chips there you go we've solved the
middle
[Music]